on a la 4e journée qualificative du
championnat de la réunion inter
entreprises et au collège d'une 14e
kilomètre de championnat corpo dans sa
7ème édition donc de plus en plus de
joie de plus en plus d' équipes donc une
vrai succès depuis depuis sept ans
maintenant 120 joueurs inscrits encore
cette année douze équipes donc bu que du
bonheur mais je crois que la commune
soit repos va perdurer encore longtemps
ils viennent chercher du sport je viens
chercher de la dynamique entre collègues
entre
entre collègues on va dire et amis et
puis la convivialité parce qu'il ya
aussi la conduire était dans l' inter
entreprises
mais qui peut un jeu de mot assez santé
kick l'adria santé bien sûr parce qu'on
est une équipe axée plus tôt santé et
techniquement le badminton sa demande de
la technicité ben voilà on n'arrive pas
comme ça on a fait un petit jeu de mot
là dessus sans technical objectif
l'ambiance à la mène aussi car il est
dur à chaque fois que des rencontres
c'est un moment où on fait surtout pour
le plaisir mais c'est ça pouvait
chercher cette partie qu'on n'a pas dans
les trois compétitions officielles
ces compétitions hormones ou plaisir
c'est quoi toutes ses couleurs les
lacets c'est quoi
you may use mais ça c'était c'était
notre capitaine de groupe caillé qui
avait lancé l'idée je vais peut-être
mais s'explique un petit peu pourquoi il
est là c'est la voilà enfin qu'on la
sait ça fait partie tryba death est très
connu dans le monde du badminton le
célibat sur un tronc ces dénonciations
pour toujours le sport les pays
défavorisés
comment s'appelle tony qui font des
profiteroles
qui et pourquoi pas parce qu'on adore
manger des procès soient non c'est pas
vrai c'est juste un jeu du moins un peu
fastidieuse et voilà les trois leur est
propre l'épreuve est pas très joli donc
pas ce qu'est ce que vous venez chercher
un séjour ni la convivialité les voiries
ghosn avait assuré la demi-tonne
sécurité patrouillent l'année hong kong
rien à voir avec les compétences
individuelles que c'est un bon moment
l'état d'esprit j'ai laissé un parallèle
entre les équilibres entre collectif et
en plus on mange bien que du peu en fait
ça dépend si tard
donc la 4e journée qualificative donc à
l'issue de cette journée là donc on aura
un classement des deux équipes et à
l'issue donc on va faire un tirage au
sort pour faire les finales
excellent ce finale élite c'est déjà une
première entrée j'irai en tenue de la
compétition est ce vrai que depuis le
début on voit que des gens ils voulaient
pas que du corpo à la base sont venus
dans les compétitions individuelles
participe au championnat de la réunion
après l'objectif quand même passer les
dom tom en ont deux
deux places de réserver aux chemins de
france inter entreprises donc la réunion
est en un seul département à avoir
décliné encore paul sont dans son
département ils ont cure à une voire
deux équipes de la réunion sur un france
en juin prochain à paris